you know what's crazy like when i was
thinking about um like boundaries and
giving up yeah i he like because he you
know he was homeless when i first met
him so i like moved him into my parents
house so he could get an id i tell you
this story it sounds like a story i've
told no so like basically he was he was
super hit a lot of money but he was
homeless and when i met him like i
remember thinking i never met a guy that
um
like i had such a lack of almost like
parents like i felt really bad because
he had no proof that he existed dude
that's a hard
thing he lost like everything but his
birth certificate that was all he had
but he couldn't get an id because he
didn't have an address i talked about
this so even
even if he didn't even if he had like
the money where would you mail it to
yeah and so my parents put him like on
our lease oh so that was how like and
they like moved him in for like he lived
with us for like a month that's it
well then we got an apartment because he
wanted to get an apartment before but
gotcha gotcha so he i get it so he lived
up i guess i have lived with a guy
technically but i don't know i don't
really count that that's in my parents
um and plus like we had separate rooms
but um good
i don't know if that makes sense
but i was just thinking like that was so
crazy i literally like met him and like
then moved him basically into my parents
house and look at where you guys are at
now
what do you mean you're not together
yeah so
makes me wonder
if subconsciously
the reason that you're not together is
because although he makes more money
he just doesn't move in the right frame
obviously i feel like we've established
that i just